sends it to the line that shot with traffic
front of Jones goes wide Aram Zoo steps up
a centering pass mle again that one off the
post pretty good job of getting the sticks
in the way and not allowing that passing Lane to
open up here's Nick Robertson looking across the
ice and Banks off Dolby walking get front and
working up a backand k Melo down to make the
stop of Kelly AR cro wide of the net close
call couple of gaping open Nets on that one
too that have both been missed High here's
Matthews picking off another scores Austin
Matthews and did it come off es skate or is it 29
chance nice job of lren jumping in on this one he
tries to go short side looked like cor Salo got
a a little bit of it but this has been a problem
with the Ottawa Senators those kind of turnovers
I was just looking at the reaction for nice it
definitely deflected and went different direction
as you can see watch right here oh just a toone
going officially it's Matthew ny's goal which
would be his eighth of the year just is second
and 10 back to the line for Riley up high he gets
it back from nean foot score this time it is Tyler
forzi the goals 23 seconds apart had the early
chance but this is again just hard work keeping
the puck alive now you've got bodies moving the
white is to the outside and just getting inside
position at the net Riley's got his head up the
whole way and bran can't get into the Stick of
forzi corus Salo doesn't use his stick to stop
the pass the left side now mcap sends it deep
again it's doy behind the net Robertson and
there's ycro in front Robertson the back hand
purple down and that shot deflecting over the
N Timothy lilligren has another look centering
pass doesn't get to ycook picked off by kachuck
oh there's Amic who saved the goal there that
one was coming up and over for the goenda hamik
right on the doorstep made the play now Matthews
able to kick it to his stick and just miss Marner
with that rightwing pass back the other way it's
Norris working in fired that off the bar Matthews
waiting on the outside of it now he weighs in it
pops out he's got two on left and it's neander
fired that off the post gave up four straight
to lose 64 and here they find themselves down
in this one here's Norah's suit was able to get
inside position and a scoring chance fired that
wide of the keage how'd he missed that he was in
tight there I don't even think that Jones knew
the puck where it was he was looking through the
defense Matthews took it away big stop coroso
ni was parked in front after another steal by
Matthews wi of the N it will Boomerang back into
the Lea Zone Len hit by here is s go St right on
rebound back in and Jones just got enough
of that two chances for St berzi from the
corner KNE Lander lurking near the net puts
it in front berzi back in and Coro with the
stop I can get on a little roll here there
was in tight just unable to get the shot he
want that would change direction in front and
pusi sends that high he's said all kinds of
looks tonight quickly on to him with was Marner
but now it's Sanderson the Matthews on him two
takeaways for Matthews in the first period and
now 34 on the year but jaru back short-handed
gets it across scores shorthanded Parker Kelly
and ottawa's within one well the play is made
and just trying to keep the play alive in the
offensive zone you're thinking power play of
course neander has got to abandon the idea of
trying to get to JW and just go to the middle
of the ice now that forces Morgan Riley to sort
of stay with JW if neander comes back and takes
the trailer Kelly he's got an opportunity
maybe to take that pass away an assist on
the N goal after the scorers took a another
look at it Matthews trying to steal it from
bson here comes stutler with a step in rebound
for and the game is tied Drake panon pass the
equalizer you know those neutral zone turnovers
with some fresh bodies out there comes in late
to this play is right here the play by Matthews
is okay it's going to go the one way instead ster
coming off the bench jumps into the hole and
that's a shot that you just take the hope to
create a rebound you know you get a good stick
by Morgan doesn't allow sta to get the shot he
wants but nobody's got BS as he follows the play
up the rebounds in the slot and there's a half an
open net there for bson that one off a stick with
Matthews loose in front and now away goes bson
who is tied it inside on lilligren BS to the net
Jones had to make a top stop there on a terrific
rushed by BS on their last power play face off
one by ottawan come Zoo three on Two And Matthews
one of the Defenders back a shot rebound and it
bounced in front that was nearly a short headed
gold brickway the other ways toar stop rebound oh
neander had it go up and out oh boy lion flat it's
Tavaris who knocks this down would this have
been high stick oh boy that was close but how
about caalo his best save and then right on the
doorstep was nean ER that looked to me a little
high neander gets his own rebound hands it off and
it'll come back to Riley over to Matthews down low
tamarus rebound oh what a stop dring Mitch martyr
now the late stages of this third power play mck
across GOI fired that rebound beri took a whack
at it break G Marner now and sm's got it back to
Sanders flipped it front deflect it Jones down and
is able to cover 51st Career Point against Toronto
and this is 48th game against the maple HCK holds
the Zone plck play near the front of the net they
had a loose man there as gsla was alone in front
of 10 how did that go in ottawa's got the lead
Street continues look at he's in front of the
net gets the little tip there as stla gets a
piece of it that's what about a foot behind the
goal line and Jones puts his glove back thinking
uhoh I felt that watch the shoulder hits the
shoulder rides up and it kind of rolls right
down his back and then finally drops down by
the time B sees it in watch where he is it's
stuck there for a couple of seconds and
then rolled back Ottawa making changes
nander advancing Over The Line tarus pass Zoo
to nander knocked off his stick open net Brady
kachu charging after it martyr TR to get back
and it's a goal for Brady kachuck and in the
empty net for his 300th NHL Point William neander
gets the little give and go here from Taris now
L Lander tries to stop up instead chck with the
good stick now you got a race for the pck and as
you said 300 there for Brady kachuck to make
it a two goal game doing the exact same on a
close call but a great save LEF l two nothing
but Ottawa scores the final four and they win
their third comeback victory of the season and
Drake bson was prominent with a pair of goals